Israel breaks stunning intelligence
information about the Iran deal the New
York Times talks up Karl Marx on his
birthday and Robert Mullins questions
for Donald Trump leak will talk about
all of it this is the Ben Shapiro show
all righty so many amazing things
happening first of all I do want to
announce this and I'll announce it again
later in the show
if you're not a subscriber to the show
you really should subscribe to the show
because on Sunday we are beginning a
brand new second podcast it's it's a
second edition the podcast the Ben
Shapiro shows Sundays special and I'm
gonna be hosting weekly in-depth
conversations with a bunch of people our
first episode actually features me
talking with jordan peterson it's a full
hour long so it's some of these five
minutes ten minute interviews we really
go in depth we're talking with folks
about politics and news and culture and
everything in between and if you're
already a subscriber you don't have to
hit another button because it's
immediately going to pop up in your feed
so it should be awesome again this
Sunday's premiere episode features
Jordan Peterson so I think that you
should subscribe I think it'll be great
and you're really going to enjoy okay so
before I get to the actual content of
the show there's a lot of news breaking
particularly about Israel and Iran first
I want to say thanks to our sponsors
over at blinds.com so there's one part
of your house you really don't think
about very much but it's making your
house look like crap and it's your
blinds okay you have the same blinds
that you had from the person who moved
in before you and that person has the
same blinds from the person who built
the house in 1937 and the blinds look
like garbage well it's making your whole
house look like garbage that's why you
need to go over to my friends over at
blinds at comm they make it really easy
for you if you're not sure what you want
or even where to start with blinds calm
you get a free online design
consultation you send them pictures of
your house and they send back custom
recommendations from a professional from
what's gonna work with your color scheme
furniture and specific rooms and they
will even send you free samples to make
sure everything looks as good in person
as it does online every order gets free
shipping here's the best part if you
screw it up you must measure you pick
the wrong color lines Comrie makes your
blinds for free so it is an awesome deal
and they've really made it easy for you
there's no excuse to leave up those
mangled blinds that make it look like
your that you've just moved into
somebody else's trailer go to blinds
calm and use promo code ban you get 20%
off everything at blinds calm for a
limited time when you use promo code ban
again that's blinds.com promo code Ben
for 20% off everything that's the faux
wood blinds the cellular shades the
roller shades and more blinds.com promo
code Ben rules and restrictions do apply
okay so the big news yesterday is that
Benjamin Netanyahu the Prime Minister of
Israel got up and did a 20-minute speech
in which he announced that Israel had
done something unbelievable Mossad had
somehow gotten ahold of 100,000 physical
files from the Iran
in government about their nuclear
program it has an amazing thing just
think of how many boxes of materials
that is you had to deliberately smuggle
out of Tehran how exactly did that
happen it's pretty incredible thing
about what's in the files is even more
stunning so number one the files detail
the extent of the Iranian nuclear
program prior to the Iran nuclear deal
Iran has always lied about that they've
said they weren't developing nuclear
weapons they just wanted a peaceful
nuclear program the files show that that
is in fact a lie also the fact that
these files had been smuggled to a
secret location demonstrates something
else which is that Iran had no intention
of dismantling its nuclear program as
Barack Obama seemed to suggest instead
they were just taking all of their files
moving them to the back room continuing
on with their secret nuclear program
probably or at the very least putting
other parts of that nuclear program on
hold for the moment while they develop
all the technology all the centrifuges
and all of the and all of the ballistic
missile technology and then in ten years
after the deal of science and now eight
years once that happens they go right
back to where they left off they pick up
all their own files they have all the
same people who've been working on this
stuff and boom in six months they have a
bomb right that is the point of the Iran
deal from where the Iranians ton that's
always what people who have opposed the
Iran deal have claimed is what the
Iranian it's were attempting to do in
the Iran deal and now it's been pretty
well documented here's what it looked
like yesterday and sounded like when
Benjamin Netanyahu spoke in front of the
world about the files that they had
gotten ahold of from the Iranians well
tonight I'm here to tell you one thing
Iran lied big-time
after signing the nuclear deal in 2015
Iran intensified its efforts to hide its
secret nuclear files and this is one of
the big questions so why exactly did
they bother hiding the nuclear files if
in fact they were intent on dismantling
their nuclear program or even on putting
it on hold why would they smuggle those
files to someplace eke rrett why would
they continue to have a defense program
staffed by exactly the same people who
are running the nuclear program if they
put their nuclear plans on hold the
answer of course is they're lying and at
the very least they are planning to
reinitiate that nuclear program as soon
as the deal is up or at the very most
they may be pursuing nuclear plans in
secret here's Netanyahu talking a little
bit about the smuggling of the files in
2017 Iran moved its nuclear weapons
files to a highly secret location in
Tehran
this is the sure about district in
southern Tehran this is where they kept
the atomic archives right here so again
pretty amazing intelligence operation
now all of the Obama acolytes are
claiming that we already knew all this
stuff that we knew that Iran was lying
about its nuclear weapons for years
that's why we tried to sign the Iran
deal in the first place because we knew
that they'd been developing nuclear
weapons why would we have attempted to
sign a deal with people if we thought
that they weren't developing nuclear
weapons okay fair enough except for the
fact that Iran then lied to the
International Atomic Energy Agency when
it came time to make the deal so one of
the provisions of the deal is that Iran
had to give all the details up of what
exactly they'd been doing with their
nuclear program in order for the deal to
go through
they didn't do that they lied about what
they were doing they took all those
files they hid them because again they
plan on opening those files right back
up as soon as this deal is up and then
developing a nuclear weapon within six
months that is their big plan here the
fact that all of the Obama friends are
out there defending Iran today and
suggesting that Iran is honest and that
Bibi Netanyahu is a liar tells you
pretty much what you need to know about
the Obama folks remember that Iran deal
which is an awful awful deal does not
include ballistic weapons technology so
it means that the Iranians can continue
to develop long-range intercontinental
ballistic missiles without violating the
terms of the Iran deal it does not cover
the use of money given by the West back
to Iran for purposes of terrorism and so
Iran has funneled an enormous sum of
cash to Bashar Assad in Syria and
Hezbollah in Lebanon the Iran deal did
not cover any of that Obama and Kerry
openly admitted that we the United
States are currently funding Iranian
terror projects but that is something
that is currently happening and yet we
are told that that Iran's deal is so
important that we have to maintain it
we're told it's really deeply important
for us to maintain the Iran deal in a
second I'm gonna make the case for those
on the right who say we should maintain
the Iran deal versus those who say we
should just scrap the thing but it is
important to note the other place in
which the Obama administration lied they
lied openly openly about the supposed
moderation of the Iranian regime so the
story that was sold by Ben Rhodes who is
a fiction writer who somehow ended up
his national security adviser under
Barack Obama it's amazing all these
people who say that Trump surrounds
himself with unqualified people okay
there's no way in the world the Jared
Kushner is less qualified than Ben
Rhodes because it's impossible for
anyone to be less qualified than Ben
Rhodes Ben Rhodes went from writing bad
short stories that were unpublished
his Brooklyn apartment to being National
Security Adviser because Barack Obama
was friends with him and then Ben Rhodes
constructed an entire narrative sold by
Jeffrey Goldberg of the Atlantic was a
garbage human being and in a terrible
reporter the same guy who fired Kevin
Williamson Jeffrey Goldberg is the guy
who played stooge for the Obama
administration as they proclaimed that
Iran was promulgating a new moderation
they claimed that Iran had gone moderate
that the election of Hassan rouhani as
opposed to mouthful moon Ahmadinejad was
actually a moderate move and now Iran
wanted to make a deal because Iran
obviously was moving toward the center
and if we just fostered that by reaching
out to them then very soon around with
moderate obviously that has not happened
instead the mullahs have been reinsuring
in power and strengthened in their power
by the Iran deal they have millions of
dollars flowing in they never would have
seen before I mean we shipped literally
pallets of cash was it 150 billion
dollars something like that we should
pallets of cash to the Iranians first of
all the reason we should pallets with
cash as opposed to just wiring the money
is because then it's untraceable the
Iranians know that we knew that the
Obama administration lied about the Iran
deal and they did it routinely so the
question is why is we be doing this now
the answer is that Bibi is doing this
now the Israeli Prime Minister is
revealing these documents right now
because Netanyahu is attempting to make
the case for scrapping the Iran deal two
weeks before the Trump administration
has to decide whether or not to
recertify the Iran deal and the Israelis
have been coordinating with the
Americans all throughout this process it
turns out that Netanyahu told Trump
about all of these documents two months
ago and shockingly Trump actually kept
his mouth shut about them which is
pretty pretty amazing in and of itself
the Israeli ambassador says that the US
has shared the documents with the United
States and in fact the US has
authenticated them I can guarantee you
that if people had that information in
2015 this deal would have never happened
at the time because it shows there's
hard evidence there that Iran has a
military nuclear program and that had
falsified all their reports to the IAEA
the International Atomic Energy Agency
what Netanyahu did today he did not
present simply a smoking gun he
presented a smoking bomb okay and
there's something else that's happened
in the Middle East - and you have to be
reading all of the tea leaves to see
what's really happening here there is a
Sunni Alliance that is forming against
the rise of Shia Iran that is exactly
what is happening here now does this
mean that the United States gonna go war
with
Ron no it doesn't mean the United States
is gonna go to war with Iran I don't
think the President Trump is interested
in using American military might in
order to topple the Iranian regime nor
am i certain that he should in fact I
think there's a pretty good case that
the United States should not be involved
in using military force in order to
topple the Iranian regime if there is
any way to avoid it that's why I think
that Trump is taking a step back and
he's basically saying let's weaken the
Iranian regime and then if Israel has to
do it Israel has to do then they have to
do it they have to do and they've
obviously been working hand in glove
with the Saudis how do we know that
because the Saudis came out in the last
two days and Mohammed bin Sultan who is
the new Prince over there yeah he had
the new king he has he sent something
incredible all right he came for and he
said that the Palestinians basically
ought to take whatever the Trump
administration offers them in a deal
with Israel or sit down and shut up and
the reason that they're saying this is
because the Trump administration has
said to everyone in the region look you
want to stop Iran you're gonna have to
get on the same page
hey you have to stop using the
Palestinians as a baton to wield against
the Israelis you have to stop supporting
Hamas you have to stop supporting the
Palestinian Authority and Islamic Jihad
you have to stop all of that and instead
you need to understand that you guys
face a common enemy and the Saudis
understand that the Israelis obviously
understand it too so what we have now is
a working alliance between Jordan Egypt
Saudi Arabia and Israel against Iran and
that alliance has been formulated with
the end of the Iran deal in mind I'd be
very surprised at this point if the
Trump administration does not in fact
tip over the Iran deal in a couple of
weeks now the case against tipping over
the Iran deal is that Iran is
quote-unquote abiding by the agreement
which means that they are not actively
developing their nuclear program for the
moment and the question is really timing
right is everybody ready for what comes
next if the Iran deal ends so if the
Iran deal ends presumably the United
States reimpose the sanctions on Iran
the Europeans do not there's been of a
foreign policy snafu there because Obama
has of course put the onus on the West
not on the Iranians to prove that Iran
is is line which is I think kind of
ridiculous because Iran has been lying
continuously about the stuff for decades
and so the question becomes okay what
happens after that and the answer is
that once that once the sanctions are
reinforced once the Iran deal is off the
table the real purpose of that is to
allow Israel to work with Saudi Arabia
to strike at Iran's nuclear facilities
and that's really what this is about so
will that kind of feel great into a
larger war I don't think so
I think the the chances of that
spiraling out of control with the
Iranians attacking the United States for
example they'd be fools to do
so and the Russians are not going to
jump in against the Israelis and the
Saudis because they understand that that
would precipitate American military
action so this would be probably a very
contained military response by Israel
and by Saudi Arabia which should have
been pursued years and years and years
ago
if this Iran zeal were to end if it's
not to end my guess the only reason for
doing that is because they haven't come
up with a foolproof military plan at
this point and so the goal here is to
kick the can down the road until they
actually have something ready to go well
with all that and I have I think a
pretty good sign that what I'm saying is
true which I'll explain to you in just
one second but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Barroso
think about it all of your modern and
luxury items come in boxes your mattress
your clothes your eyeglasses well now
luxury couches actually come in boxes
too no more heavy lifting no more
digging your walls when you're moving in
because of burrows so we at our house
have some burrow furniture and it is
just the most comfortable stuff not only
that some of the furniture has USB
outlets in it so if I'm sitting there
and I have to charge my phone I can sit
there on the couch doing it on a
stretcher a wire all the way across the
room there their fabric is stain
resistant which is great because I have
two kids who make messes out of
everything burrow burns style and
comfort to a whole new level and they
shipped to your door fast and Freight is
affordable luxury it's the same quality
that you would expect from high-end
retailers without pranky without
breaking the bank and what's really cool
is the burro is adaptable so all of
their furniture is modular so if your
space changes then you can actually move
the furniture around and it grows with
you so you get a couch that expands you
can get chairs that have a place for
some for another piece in the middle
it's really cool and again they have
that stain resistant fabric that can
take on your pets claws and it has that
built-in USB charger so it's got
durability it's got functionality so you
can enjoy 30 days of cozy on your burro
for risk free or try out burrow at one
of their showrooms today so you can try
out for 30 days and if you don't like it
then they'll take it back for free go
customize your own burrow and get 75
bucks off your order right now by going
to burrow comm / ben shapiro
that's bu rrow dot-com / ben shapiro
burrow comm / ben shapiro for 75 bucks
off your purchase this is furniture
that's gonna last you a long time and it
looks really good and it is super
comfortable Burrow comm / Ben Shapiro
for 75 bucks off your purchase again
they make the luxury couch for real life
their burrow furnitures just terrific
burrows calm / Ben Shapiro for that deal
and to let them know that we sent you so
I've said that I think the indicators
are
pretty good that the White House is
going to pull out of the Iran ziyal
what is the chief indicator well
yesterday there was a statement that
came out from the press secretary the
office of the press secretary from the
White House and here's what it said the
United States is aware of the
information just released by Israel and
continues to examine it carefully this
information provides new and compelling
details about Iran's efforts to develop
missile deliverable nuclear weapons
these facts are consistent with what the
United States has long known Iran has a
robust clandestine nuclear weapons
program that it has tried and failed to
hide from the world and from its own
people okay so they're a bunch of
reporters who pointed out this is a
pretty stunning statement right they're
not saying that Iran had a robust
clandestine nuclear weapons program
they're saying that it has an active
weapons program which would obviously be
a violation of the deal and mean that we
have to pull out of the deal immediately
well the White House came out afterward
and they changed the language they
changed to Iran had a robust clandestine
weapons nuclear nuclear weapons program
the White House said it was a clerical
error but there's very little there's
very little question as to where the
White House's head is at right the White
House believes that the nuclear deal is
bad Barack Barack Obama knew it was bad
but did it anyway and lied to the
American people about it Trump has been
saying for years that the Iran deal is a
disaster and President Trump is right
now as I say none of this means the
United States has to go to war the
United States can do a lot of things
short of going to war we can reimpose
sanctions we can help facilitate the use
of Saudi airspace by the Israelis we can
ensure that Israel is defended in case
of retaliatory strike but that doesn't
mean that we have to go to active war
with the Iranians we can support
revolutionary movements within Iran in a
stronger possible fashion if we have the
sanctions reinforced it's very difficult
to support people trying to topple a
regime when you have a deal with the
regime that's why I've always found the
Obama line that it was either his deal
or war to be so foolish and such a lie
he's not the only one saying it of
course pat buchanan who really despises
israel he's been saying the same thing
here is buchanan making that case so you
didn't watch TV Netanyahu's evidence and
believe it today because I believed
every word of it
I believe Netanyahu with due respect
wants the United States to fight a war
against Iran when Israel but he's
talking about fighting a war my country
getting into another I don't
another war either okay again this is a
lie when you have people like Pat
Buchanan saying that everything is
inevitably going to lead to war that's
nonsense
it is worth noting by the way that the
Israel was very tepid about the Iraq war
in the first place for all the people
who keep saying that Israel was the
cause of the Iraq war go back and look
at the evidence the Israeli government
was really not something for the Iraq
war they were very very torn about
whether the United States should go to
war in Iraq in the first place that was
a George W Bush initiative I think it
was right initiative at the time based
on the evidence that he had in front of
him but yeah again the sort of pat
buchanan it--
this is a war on behalf of the jews
routine i don't think that's right
especially because as iranian influence
goes in the region that threatens a lot
of american interests aside from israel
including Saudi Arabia including the the
fate of Europe including American troops
that are stationed around the world Iran
developing the sort of technology is
extraordinarily dangerous especially
considering that Iran has such close
relationships with a bunch of terror
groups you talk about Iran as the
greatest state terrorist state terror
sponsor on planet earth that is
obviously the case okay
now meanwhile in other news I just have
to comment on Maxine water so Maxine
Waters
came out yesterday and she's talking
about Kanye West now I'm growing tired
of talking about Kanye West I think that
Kanye West did something great and over
the past few days he's been tweeting out
quotes from Thomas Sowell
and all of that's really good so I think
Kanye is a political expert no I don't
think he's a political expert but again
kudos to Kanye for attempting to have
conversations about politics in a
fashion that doesn't fit directly into
the jigsaw puzzle that the Democrats
have built for him he's been saying that
you know you should think for yourself
on politics he's been saying that we
don't have to be stuck on a particular
political plantation honestly good for
him for saying all of that while Maxine
Waters has had enough the representative
from California
who is one of the more adult ish members
of Congress I mean she's really stupid
human being Maxine Waters tore into
Kanye West and here's what she said she
said quote Kanye West is a very creative
young man but we also think that
sometimes West talks out of turn and
perhaps he needs some assistance in
helping him to formulate some of his
thoughts as he Kanye West needs Maxine
Waters to guide him because he's too
stupid we don't think that he actually
means to do harm but we're not sure he
really understands the impact of what
he's saying at the time that he's saying
it and how that weighs on particularly
African American community and for young
people in general and then she continued
quote I understand that he is getting
pushback from a lot of young people on
the Internet
we're hopeful that his creativity will
continue to be demonstrated in his work
and I think maybe you should think twice
about politics and maybe not have so
much to say so this is pretty amazing
because she's essentially telling Kanye
West to shut up and sing that's exactly
what that last sentence is he should
think twice about politics and maybe
have not so much to say and he should
continue to show his creativity in his
work so let's get this straight when
Laura Ingraham said to LeBron James shut
up and dribble that was racist when
Maxim water says to Kanye West shut up
and sing that's just her what being
great advisor a great adviser to Kanye
West first of all for her to claim that
anyone is ignorant is insane okay
again Maxine Waters is one of the more
corrupt stupid members of Congress as a
woman who while she was hitting on the
House Financial Services Committee was
named by Judicial Watch the most corrupt
member of Congress I think four times
because she was attempting to use the
House Financial Services Committee
allegedly to funnel money and make
exceptions for her husband's Bank one
United Bank had a bunch of stock in the
bank as for her stupidity there's a lady
who once said that Vladimir Putin was
going to invade at Korea not Crimea
she said she once said that she was she
said I was once a millennial no she was
not she promoted abortion by saying I
have to March because my mother could
not have an abortion which is a good
reason for you not to March because if
your mom had had an abortion you
wouldn't be there but again Maxine
Waters the entire left a lot of folks on
the Left very very upset with Kanye West
for daring to step outside of the of the
typical box that has been built for all
of these folks on the left here in
Hollywood this box has been built for
you if you are a black person this box
has been built for you and so if you
step outside the box that Maxine Waters
will clock you again if you step outside
any box the left will clock you in the
resistance to this I think is growing
exceedingly strong then a lot of people
right now who are feeling like you've
been hemming me and I think by the way a
lot of trumps appeal in 2016 was based
on the idea that he was breaking out of
the box of political correctness I think
a lot of the stuff he said wasn't
politically incorrect I think it was
dumb but the fact that he was willing to
say things that were politically
incorrect from time to time was one of
his chief appeals and Hillary Clinton
made a huge mistake politically by
reinforcing the perception of a lot of
mayor of a lot of Americans that the
left wants to build a small box for you
to live in and if you go outside the box
then she will call you a deplorable and
Donald Trump said listen I hate boxes
boxes are stupid
the corners hurt I don't want them and
then he's blew up the box yeah I think
that a lot of people felt the appeal of
that and a lot of people are feeling the
appeal of that now which is great which
is great I think Kanye West is one of
the people feeling the appeal of that
now does there still have to be some
sort of box for acceptable opinion and
unacceptable opinion I think most people
agree then not all opinion is created
equal and not all opinion is equally
valuable but I think that if we're going
to err on the side of the size of the
box we have to err on the side of a
large box a box that fits a lot of
opinions and again a black person saying
they want to vote Republican or consider
Republican voting is is not the end of
the world
and it's also worth noting that there's
a lot of disinformation being put out
that the Democratic left in an attempt
to win Kanye West back like they keep
putting out the myth that the Republican
and Democratic parties switch places on
race in the 1960s that is eminently
untrue it's been disproved by people
ranging from Shawn trend of Real Clear
Politics to a couple of professors I
believe at Princeton and the statistics
just do not bear this out but good for
Kanye West and bad for Maxine Waters
again cudgelling people into line seems
to be the the main priority of so many
folks on the Left which is really really
unfortunate these days okay so before I
go any further and I have to talk about
the New York Times which is celebrating
Karl Marx's birthday I am not kidding
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at thrive market so check
out thrive market calm slash Shapiro for
great savings on all the products you
need to live a healthy life so if you're
like me you care a lot about health I
work out every day and that is why
beneath this this non-threatening
exterior lies the Hulk of a monster but
one of the things I'm also careful about
is not just the working out but also the
stuff that I put in my body and that's
why I like to eat healthy food as much
as I can for somebody who hates
vegetables one of the ways that I do
that is by shopping over at thrive
market they're a revolutionary online
marketplace on a mission to make healthy
living easy and affordable for everyone
you can actually shop for thousands of
the best-selling non-gmo foods and
natural products always at twenty five
to fifty percent below traditional
retail prices and check out the thrive
market brand products because they are
the highest quality ingredients at even
more affordable prices than the current
premium products that they carry on
their site and you can get everything
you need and it's all organized this is
a nice thing right you can actually
filter the catalog by our values and
dietary preferences so for me that's
awesome because I can search with one
click of a button for every
that is kosher and that means that I
know what I can eat at thrive market and
again more than 70% of the thrive market
catalogue cannot be found on Amazon it's
all top quality stuff it's hot it's
highly curated so it's only the best of
each individual product and here is how
it works users right now get 20% rather
$20 off their first three orders of 49
bucks or more plus free shipping so most
shoppers spend more than 49 bucks on the
site anyway
do the math you spend 49 bucks and
thrive automatically gives you back 20
bucks so your total purchase becomes $30
and you get that deal three times in a
row
pretty awesome deal go to thrive market
calm slash Schapiro that's thrive market
calm slasher pro2 get your instant 60
bucks of free groceries again for each
time you spend forty nine bucks you get
20 bucks off thrive market calm slash
appear Oh check it out use that slash
apparel so that they know that we sent
you okay so the good news is that while
the left may be attempting to box
everybody in with identity politics they
are also attempting to revivify the the
ghost of Karl Marx so the New York Times
has written a bunch of pieces in the
last year about why Marxism is awesome
which is pretty amazing because then
they charge you a pretty high
subscription for you to be over at the
New York Times but well they've written
op eds in the last year titled when
communism inspired Americans socialism's
future maybe his past and why women had
better sex under socialism which seems
wildly untrue considering that the
better sex under socialism of China
involves forced abortion which seems
like that might kill the mood a little
bit in any case there's another piece
out yesterday that I just love from a
guy named Jason Barker he's an associate
professor of philosophy over at a South
Korean University and the piece is
called happy birthday Karl Marx you were
right and there's a picture of a giant
statue of Karl Marx I mean not only was
Karl Marx not right Karl Marx's idiotic
philosophy led to the deaths of well
over a hundred million people during the
20th century alone so if that's right
then I don't want to be right anytime
soon but here is what this professor
writes he writes on May 5th 1818 in the
southern German town of Trier in the
picturesque wine-growing region of the
Moselle Valley Karl Marx was born at the
time Trier was one tenth the size it is
today with a population of around 12,000
according to one of Marx's recent
biographers Jurgen F sure is one of
those towns where although everyone
doesn't know everyone many know a lot
about many
such provincial constraints were no
match from Marx's boundless intellectual
enthusiasm rare worth of radical
thinkers of the major European capitals
of his day that had either failed to
meet or it failed to break with on
theoretical grounds and then he talks
about all of his all of his intellectual
influences and he says in nineteen in
1837 Marx reneged on the legal career
that his father himself a lawyer had
mapped out for him and immersed himself
instead in the speculative philosophy of
GWF Hegel at the University of Berlin if
you've never read Hegelian philosophy
don't worry about it it's incredibly
abstruse and difficult to read but the
basic idea of hegelian philosophy is
that God is present in history and that
history is essentially a progression
from synthesis and from from thesis and
antithesis to synthesis in other words
there's one position the opposite
position they fight with each other and
the result is a synthesis of the best of
both positions and therefore history is
constantly moving in a progressive
direction that is Hegelian ism in two
sentences right there okay but what Marx
took from that is that history was going
to move inevitably away from capitalism
and instead toward communism so here is
what Barker writes is if the resemblance
in case to be made for the dangers of
philosophy then surely it's Marx's
discovery of Hegel whose grotesque
craggy melody repelled him at first but
which soon had him dancing deliriously
through the streets of Berlin as Marx
confessed to his father in an equally
delirious letter in November 1837 I
wanted to embrace every person standing
on the street corner and here's what
barking rides as we reach the
Bicentennial of Marx's birth what
lessons might we draw from his dangerous
and delirious philosophical legacy what
precisely is Marx's lasting contribution
today the legacy would be it would
appear to be alive and well if by alive
and well you mean the Soviet Union no
longer exists after a century of
oppression and that the Chinese have
embraced non Marxist philosophy and that
the last standing vestige of true
Marxism on planet Earth is probably in
Cuba and North Korea to gulag States
then sure everything is going great for
Marxism oh yeah and there's Venezuela
also which has just been a boon since
the turn of the millennium countless
books have appeared from scholarly works
to popular biographies writes this
professor in the New York Times broadly
endorsing Marx his reading of capitalism
and its enduring relevance for
neoliberal age in 2002 the French
philosopher Alain Badiou declared at a
conference I attended in London that
Marx had become the philosopher of the
middle class what did he mean I believe
he meant that educated liberal opinion
is today more or less unanimous in its
agreement that Marx basic thesis that
capitalism is driven by a deeply
divisive class struggle in which the
ruling class minority appropriates the
surplus labor of the working-class
majority as profit is correct even
liberal economists such as Nouriel
Roubini agree that Marxist conviction
that capitalism has an inbuilt tendency
to destroy itself remains as prescience
as ever well okay a couple of things
that are wrong with this one
Marx's basic theory which is that rich
people exploit poor people for their own
profit is idiotic now unless you can
demonstrate that there is force that is
being used the fact is that capitalism
has raised more people out of poverty
than anything else in the history of
humanity and it is not closed okay in
1980 twice the number of people as today
we're living in abject poverty on planet
earth today less than 10% of all people
on planet earth are living in what they
call extreme poverty by UN standards
that is solely due to free trade and
capitalism is that this idea that Marx's
thesis is right that it's all about
class warfare no if you're an educated
person and you've actually studied the
issues you don't believe this you have
to be a fool to believe this you have to
be a college educated Bernie Sanders
spouting idiot to believe this stuff but
here's the part that I thought I loved
about Barker so here's what he talks
about he says Marx arrives at no magic
formula for exiting the normal and the
enormous social and economic
contradictions that global capitalism
entails what Marx did achieve however
through his self-styled materialist
thought were the critical weapons for
undermining capitalism is ideological
claim to be the only game in town
so what exactly does he say is the way
that capitalism is going to fall Marx
according to this professor in the New
York Times celebrating Marx well Marx
was convinced the capitalism and to make
relics of Kappa that capitalism is to
make relics of all of these workers all
these various type of workers the
inroads that artificial intelligence is
currently making into medical diagnosis
and surgery for instance bears out the
argument in the manifesto that
technology would greatly accelerate the
division of labor or the descaling of
such professions ok first of all here he
has picked an incredibly poor example my
wife has mentioned many times on the
show is a doctor the fact that she is
capable of using medical technology to
diagnose has made her a better doctor it
has not declined it is not it does not
reduce the demand for doctors we saw the
shortage of doctors in the United States
largely thanks to the regulatory
policies of the federal government but I
visit this is my favorite part so then
he talks about how how what we really
need here is something new he says we
need a classless and stateless society
raises we're Hagel had stopped it
advocating a rational liberal state Marx
would go one stage further since the
gods were no longer divine there was no
need for a state at all so it's not that
the state existed in history and the God
existed in history it's there was no
need for a state instead we could have a
classless stateless society that would
come to define both Marx and Engels idea
of communism and of course the
subsequent and troubled history of the
communist states that materialized
during the 20th century and I love this
part he says there are still a great
tools we learn from their disasters but
their philosophical relevance remains
doubtful to say the least so just to get
this straight according to this
particular professor of philosophy at a
South Korean University writing in the
New York Times the history of Marxism
can be completely separated off from the
history of the USSR China North Korea
Cuba Venezuela and every other state
that has attempted state-sponsored
communism and none of that has any
philosophical relevance right there sort
of Herot historical curiosities weird
that they all thought they were
interpreting Marx too but apparently
this guy's the only guy who understands
Marx this is the best part right he's so
he Ricky talks about where Marxism
really exists and this is actually
important hey here's the part that's
important not just that the New York
Times is celebrating Marx this part then
Bowser eats you is important because you
need to understand that what he says
here is true the Marxist roots of
identity politics are very clear and
they are very disturbing he of course
thinks it's great he says the key factor
in Marx's intellectual legacy in our
present-day society is not philosophy
about critique or what he described in
1843 as quote the ruthless criticism of
all that exists ruthless both in the
sense of not being afraid of the results
it arrives at and in the sense of being
just as little afraid of the conflicts
with the powers that be the philosophers
have only interpreted the world in
various ways the point is to change it
Marx wrote in 1845 here's the paragraph
that matters racial and sexual
oppression have been added to the
dynamic of class exploitation social
justice movements like black lives
matter and me to owe something of an
unspoken debt to Marx through their
unapologetic targeting of the eternal
truths of our age such movements
recognize as it marks that the ideas
that rule every society are those of its
ruling class and that overturning those
ideas is fundamental to true
revolutionary progress we have become
used to the go-getting mantra that to
affect social change we first have to
change ourselves but enlightened or
rational thinking is not enough since
the norms of thinking are already skewed
by the structures of male privilege and
social hierarchy even down to the
language we use changing
Norm's entails changing the very
foundations of society so in just a
second I'm gonna explain why what I just
said there why that those two segments
those two paragraphs are deeply deeply
important first you're gonna have to go
over to daily wire.com and subscribe so
$4.99 $9.99 a month you get a
subscription to daily wire that comes
along with my show it comes along with
Michael Knowles his show and Andrew
Clavin show the rest of those shows live
also you get to view the video of the
entire interview that I'm doing this
Sunday with Jordan Peterson an hour-long
special interview with Jordan Peterson
our brand new show is launching every
Sunday we're gonna be doing an interview
with a major player a major thinker
somebody who's really making headlines
out there we're gonna be doing that
every Sunday we have some people coming
up with you're not gonna want to miss
Jordan P Jordan is just the first
that'll be really fascinating I can say
this safely it is the most intellectual
conversation that you will hear on
podcasting it's really high-level stuff
I think so check that out on Sunday and
when you get the subscription there are
added benefits that come with that as
well also you get the annual
subscription to this the leftist year's
hot or called tumbler you'll enjoy every
second about both both Jordan and I are
drinking from this during our interview
so you can see the magic I mean but
before the interview we were both supid
and then we started drinking from this
and we both became someone smart so
check out that tumbler and enjoy it also
daily wire is now available at Apple
News so if you view Apple News then you
can now read our site through Apple News
which is pretty cool all of the stuff
that we are breaking on a constant basis
again please subscribe and and please
become a subscriber because it helps us
bring you the show every day
it helps us bring you these specials as
well and if you just wanna listen for
free later iTunes SoundCloud YouTube
please subscribe please leave us review
we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
so back to this in this piece from the
New York Times what is admitted in this
piece upholding Marxism is something
really stunning what he basically is
saying is that when you look at all
these ethnic solidarity movements or the
female solidarity movement or any of
these identity politics movements these
are newfangled attempts to use Marxist
critiques to bring down society this is
true look if you go back to the 1960s
and you look at the work of a lot of
members of the Frankfurt School people
like everybody Marquess and you and if
she read them what they are saying is
that the new stand-ins for the for the
lower classes they're gonna rise up the
proletariat we're gonna rise up and take
over the system instead of doing it by
class he says we're gonna separate you
by racial group we're going to say that
you black people have been victimized by
American society and you gay people have
been victimized by American Society and
you Hispanic people and you Jewish
people and you women and you
transgenders you've all been says that
you've all been hurt by American society
now rise up and tear down your oppressor
the new Marxist revolution is happening
but it's not happening on the basis of
class it's happening on basis of
identity and Marxist know that now their
whole goal here is to tear down the
system and what they say is that once we
have a classless society and all this
will go away and this is why when you
hear Bernie Sanders talk it's really
kind of ironic and hilarious when Bernie
Sanders talks he is talking the language
of Marxism on behalf of identity
politics but the identity politics
movement has grown so strong that it's
now at war with some of its Marxist
roots what I mean by that is that when
you listen to Bernie what Bernie
basically says is look all these
identity politics groups are being
oppressed they're being oppressed the
way they are not going to be oppressed
anymore is when there's a socialist
utopia when we have a socialist utopia
in which income is redistributed and in
which people at the top are stamped on
and people at the bottom are uplifted
then there will be no more racism
there'll be no more sexism there'll be
no more homophobia and transphobia
everyone will get along everyone will
love his brother socialism will be the
solution well that was the message that
was being put forth by all of the
advocates of identity politics who
originally started the identity politics
advocacy in the 1960s and 70s
okay so bernie is just spouting what he
knows from his 1960s commune time but
the identity politics advocates they say
well
bernie is not paying enough attention to
us it demarks us aren't paying enough
attention to us they don't understand
even if we tear down the current cap
system and we put in its place a
socialist system that's not enough
identity politics tribalism actually
overcomes Marxism in their rubric and so
what you're seeing right now and it's
fascinating to watch is it an ongoing
fight between the identity politics wing
of the Democratic Party and the Marxist
wing of the Democratic Party and they're
going to war with each other even though
the Marxist wing created the identity
politics one it's really quite
fascinating but it is important to note
that the goal of all of this the common
cause is to tear down the capitalist
system to tear it down the social
hierarchies that lys opposes social
hierarchies based on race not on merit
right none of that is true okay what
exist in the United States right now is
a meritocracy what exist in the United
States by and large without government
regulation is a free and open country
where he can fall or rise on your own
merit yeah that's a very good thing but
Marxists believe that all of that has to
fall and they are using identity
politics as a tool in tearing down the
social order the final paragraph from
Jason Barker over the New York Times is
pretty amazing he says the transition to
a new society where relations among
people rather than capital relations
finally determine an individual's worth
is arguably proving to be quite a task
first of all it's hard to say what
exactly that's supposed to mean you know
I do judge all the individuals around me
not based on how much money they make
but whether they are good people
in fact that's been a religious
principle since the beginning of
religion that you're supposed to judge
people not on the amount of money that
they make you're not supposed to judge
their worth by their income but by how
they are as human beings but Marxism
says that we can somehow quantify that
in such a way that we can pay people in
accordance with their virtue which is
really weird and I think untrue but
Barker concludes Marx as I have said
does not offer one-size-fits-all formula
for enacting social change but he does
offer a powerful intellectual acid test
for that change on that basis we are
destined to keep citing him and testing
his ideas until the kind of society that
he struggled to bring about and that
increasing numbers of us now desire is
finally realized so we're just gonna
keep repeating Marx's routine until
Marx's dream is realized
Marx's dream was realized and it was a
dystopian nightmare but the New York
Times and leftist - all over the world
refused to recognize that because that
is their last best hope for the
replacement of a judeo-christian value
system with a system of their own making
they tried bureaucratic centralization
and top-down running things that didn't
work in the early 20th century they
tried fascism ok fascism was a left-wing
movement Mussolini began by
Marx okay Hitler to began by being
entranced with some of the ideas of Marx
and Hegel all of these things were left
with movements by European standards
that he came right wing movements
because they became counter communist
but that does not mean but by American
standards these were right-wing
movements ok fascism Italian fascism
if place in the United States would have
been much closer to FDR then it would
have been close to Wendell Willkie and
the same thing is true of Hitler's
politics but the fact is that the left
is never going to let go of the Marxist
dream because the left looks at human
beings they say human beings suck the
only way to transform them is by
transforming the system religion looks
at human beings and says human being
suck the only way to transform human
beings is where human beings to
transform themselves and to become
better human beings it's not about the
system it's about you one of those
philosophies leads to better human
beings the other philosophy leads to
horrible societies horrible societies as
a general rule okay so in just one
second I want to talk about some big
breaking news and that of course is
chaos in the Muller investigation as
some of Muller's questions are leaked
before I get to the mo of questions
though I just have to note one quick
thing that's pretty amazing so you know
I live in Los Angeles I've spent a lot
of time at my entire life basically in
left-wing areas Los Angeles Cambridge
Massachusetts and that means that I know
a lot of folks on the left and a lot of
folks on the Left who like to talk about
how terrible the United States is how
racist and awful it is and spend all of
their time I was trying to effectuate
social change spend all of their time
trying to fix the ills of society trying
to tear down the hierarchies in order to
build a new beautiful classless society
a lot of those people are totally full
of crap
how do I know this because when it comes
time for those same rules to be applied
in their backyard suddenly it becomes
not so interested okay the latest case
in point here is white residents of New
York City's Upper West Side complaining
about the idea that they're going to
have to take in a bunch of low-income
minority people into their school so the
college fix is reporting the raw story
which is not a right-leaning news
organization caught this meeting on tape
this is a meeting of residents in New
York's Upper West Side at a meeting of
the local school district and
progressive parents find out that their
schools will soon have to reflect the
demographics of New York as a whole and
the schools in the area are currently
predominantly white and they get really
mad watch as these white parents become
very upset about the idea of having to
allow low-income minority children into
their school
an emotional meeting on the Upper West
Side parents objecting to a proposal to
require each of the 17 local middle
schools to reserve a quarter of their
seats for students scoring below grade
level on state English and math exams
some parents warning that high
performing students would be shut out of
the most desirable schools
[Music]
okay so I love that all these people who
presumably voted for Bill DeBlasio and
love the idea of forced busing is alone
so long as it's not in their
neighborhood as soon as it comes into
their neighborhood that's like no no no
no no no right these are the same people
who send everyone down south is racist
but on the Upper West Side of New York
they're saying we don't want those
low-income black kids in our school cuz
gonna ruin our school this is by the way
is why I believe that public education
in general is a serious problem that has
to be rectified by local answers I can't
be rectified by government at a broader
level because all that's gonna happen by
the way here's what's really gonna
happen is that there will be demographic
changes in these schools the parents
will just pull their kids out and put
them in private school right that's
exactly what's going to happen because
that's what's been happening in the
United States for years and years and
years and years beyond which I'm not
sure that the schools are generally the
problem I think that very often the
circumstances in which people grow up
are much more defining is whether you're
gonna be a success later in life than
the school to which you went as an
elementary school student I think one of
the great myths of our public education
system is that if you went to a really
solid public school when you were five
that that is more indicative of your
success level than whether you had a
single mom or grew up in poverty in an
area with with a lot of crime I just
don't think that's right I think that
generally the two things tend to be
linked but that's more of a statement
about the the culture and society in
which you grew up again not having
nothing to with color because there are
plenty of poor white societies that have
crappy public schools as well
dumping more money and gonna fix it I'm
not sure the force bucks busing is gonna
fix it either but I want to point but I
can say that because that's what I
believe I'm not sure the people on the
Upper West Side who'd say that I'd be
horrible for saying that are allowed to
say that and all the people on the Upper
West Side who are listening to this okay
if you think that it's horrible and
racist to suggest that maybe I should be
able to put my kid where I want to put
my kid in school and that kids
should have school vouchers so they can
put their kids where they want they can
put they can go where they want to
school if you think that that is racist
and awful
let me just suggest that if you go to
your local school meeting and rant and
rave about a bunch of black kids coming
to your school because you think it's
gonna lower the educational credentials
your school maybe you ought to take a
look in the mirror maybe you ought to
take a look in the mirror and I'm not
suggesting those black kids can't come
to your school at all in fact I think
they should be able to pay to come to
the school of vouchers I'm suggesting
that there are these gated communities
that exist with public tax dollars that
are a serious problem in a lot of these
areas and and that your objection on the
left to people going to private school
is really an objection that you should
be applying to yourself because at least
people who go to private school aren't
taking advantage of public money to send
their kids to gated communities okay so
in just a second I want to discuss the
situation with with with robert muller
so here's the situation here's the
here's the latest okay so on monday
there's a new report from the new york
times and reveal dozens of questions
special counsel robert muller wanted to
ask President Trump if he agrees to an
interview for the Russia probe so this
is reported by Ryan saavedra over at
Daily wire some of the questions Mulla
reportedly wants to ask Trump include
what did you know about phone calls that
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn made with the Russian ambassador
Sergei kiss lyac in December 2016 what
did you know about Sally Yates his
meetings about mr. Flynn how is the
decision made to fire mr. Flynn what was
your opinion of James Comey during the
transition what did you think about
commis intelligence briefing on January
6 2017 about Russian election
interference what was the purpose of
your calls to mr. Comey why did you
decide to fire him now here is the big
problem with all of this okay there is
pretty much not a lot here about
supposed connections to Russia so here's
some of the questions being asked about
the original Trump Russia collusion
right then remember this whole
investigation was originally about the
idea that Vladimir Putin had been
working with Donald Trump to steal the
election here are some of the questions
he's going to ask when did you become
aware of the Trump Tower meeting this is
the one between Donald Trump jr. and a
couple of Trump officials and a Russian
lawyer what involvement did you have in
the communication strategy including the
release of Donald's from Jr's emails
during the 2013 trip to Russia what
communication and relationships did you
have with the Aguila ROVs and Russian
government officials during the campaign
what did you know about Russian hacking
use of social media or other acts aimed
at the campaign when knowledge did you
have any outreach by Matt Paul Manafort
to Russia so we'll have to see whether
this is more aimed at collusion or
whether this is more aimed at
obstruction it seems like very little
about his aims at the collusion because
if they actually had evidence of
collusion then they'd be going after
Trump and his people already I assume I
mean if they actually had evidence
evidence of conspiracy to violate
campaign law then I assume they would
already be going after people so this
really goes to intent right what they're
really trying for here is that Trump
intended to do stuff and then he was
obstructing justice by firing people but
it doesn't sound like they have the
goods
just from a list of questions that they
have that they have put forth again I
feel like Trump would be a fool to get
in a room with Muller because Muller
could catch them in some sort of perjury
trap but you know maybe Rudy Giuliani
thinks differently we will find out okay
time for a thing I'll thing I both like
and hate will do a combined thing I like
and hate so here is the thing that I
both like and hate Avengers infinity war
so I have many thoughts on Avengers
infinity war and if you haven't seen the
movie yet now is the time for you to cut
too short today's podcast and then go
back and listen to it a little bit later
after you've actually seen the movie if
you're one of the five people in America
who have not seen the movie yet sorry
for those in the room who have not yet
seen the movie I'm about to spoil a
bunch of crap for you so Mathis it's
time for you to turn off your your
earphones and then walk out of the room
if you don't want to be spoiled because
I'm about to say a lot of stuff that's
about spoiled movie okay so first of all
the movie is well-made it's it's really
well-made considering they have to
juggle about 83 different plot lines and
you can see from the poster that it's
every person in the world in one movie
the truth is the real focus of this
movie the real focus of this movie is
Iron Man Thor and the guardians of the
galaxy those are those are really the
people who you're following during this
film Captain America is not in the film
very much at all here's a little bit of
preview from one of the five people in
America who didn't see the preview
here's a little bit of what the movie
looks like the entire time I knew
he only ever had one goal
[Music]
to wipe out half the universe if he gets
all the Infinity stones she can do it
with the snap of his fingers just like
that tell me his name again
Santos
[Music]
we got one advantage
she's coming to us
we have with dance once so that's what
we use
okay so everybody's in the movie like
everyone including my mother like
everyone is in this film but well here's
my problem with the movie so I have a
couple of problems with them here's this
first the stuff I like the stuff that I
like is everything with Chris Pratt and
Chris Hemsworth is hysterical Chris
Hemsworth is the best thing in any of
the Marvel movies now he is really
really funny everything he does here is
very thor ragnarok based and it's there
there's one scene particularly between
Chris Pratt and Chris Hemsworth
that is just hysterically funny and and
really really good Chris Pratt is really
good in this I it's pretty obvious who
the stars are and this here in LA and
and beyond that Thanos as a character is
is a good character so Josh Brolin turns
in a really solid performance as Thanos
you don't notice the CGI at all and his
entire character is CGI'd so that's a
pretty cool thing there are a couple
problems with Dan OSes character problem
number one is that his motivation is
insufficiently spelled out so they say
that he had a home planet his home
planet was basically overpopulated and
the entire planet died in poverty he had
said let's randomly kill half the planet
and then we can fix and then we can
prevent a shortage on pianos on pianos
his home planet
that's Malthusian nonsense so first of
all somebody should have explained to
him that perhaps with additional
creativity of humanoid creatures comes
additional propensity to create awesome
resources so back in the 1960s Paul
Ehrlich predicted that by the year 1990
half the population would be starving
basically none of that ended up being
true so Thanos is basically Paul Ehrlich
the Stanford professor with less hair
and Paul Eric was totally wrong he's
wrong but everything people are more
prosperous now there are more of us now
than ever before in human history by a
long margin and yet things are okay
somebody should have honestly this movie
could have been solved if somebody sat
Thomas soul down with Thanos like that
would have fixed everything
they should've gotten Julian Simons
ghost to sit down with Thanos and they
could have had a nice conversation about
scarcity of resources and allocation of
those resources also if it turns out
that overpopulation is the thing among
humanoid creatures typically people just
have fewer kids which is what has
happened in throughout human history
which is why as countries get richer
it's actually interesting as countries
get richer people have fewer kids but
aside from the philosophical problems
with Danos the movie revolves around
Thanos so every beat
of the movie is involved with thanasis
story it really is not Avengers infinity
war it really more is Thanos the origins
because this is all lead up to Avengers
infinity War part two and this is my big
problem with the movie my big problem
with the movie is that the entire thing
is leading up to this giant climax where
a bunch of people are gonna get killed
and suffice it to say without telling
you who gets killed a bunch of major
characters get killed there are some
characters who get killed for real but
it is very obvious by the end of the
movie and some of the characters who
have been killed are not going to remain
dead zone okay now the reason that I
know this is because I'm not a stupid
human and when I watch the end of
infinity war and bad stuff happens let's
just I don't fully spoil it bad stuff
happens to many of the major characters
there are certain characters where you
go oh man I can't believe they killed
that guy off and then they kill off a
couple of characters you're like nah nah
these it turns out that Marvel is a
Disney property and Marvel is not gonna
kill off all of its most bankable stars
because they have movies already slated
on the books with these stars okay so
they're not gonna kill off like you're
you know who I'm talking about but
there's there's one character in
particular who's been in a film that
made a lot of money as in all the money
they're not gonna kill off that
character right and when you're watching
it and you're and you're thinking about
it the minute it happens it takes you
immediately out of the movie because
you're thinking nah this is not true so
in other words we got a two hour 40
minute movie leading up to the worst red
herring in the world in which presumably
all these characters are dead but we
know they're not really dead because
they're gonna reverse and they're gonna
write back all the characters that
annoys the living crap out of me because
if you're going to create this idea that
there are major stakes in the movie if
you're gonna create this idea that deep
horrible things are going to happen then
you can't do it with me as the audience
knowing that you're faking with me as
the audience no you're lying like the
first time it happens the first time
somebody dies and it's a major character
at the end of the film there are a
couple major deaths before that in the
film and those ones I think are real by
the time they get to the end of the film
when a major character dies and you know
that that person is not gonna die you're
like but what so why couldn't we have
just had like a seven minute movie like
sure it was fun and all but we could
have had like a seven minute movie and
the seven minute movie would have gone
something like this right would have
gone something like this it would have
been a Star Wars crawl it says Thanos
scourge of the universe has found a box
with six Infinity stones in it flash
back to Dan
on his home planet debating with his
friends and family about whether they
should kill off half the population him
losing the debate half the population
dying right just like jor-el on Krypton
right and then next thing you know it
shows Stannis with his magic glove on
right he snaps and then you get the end
of the movie so the whole thing could've
been eight minutes long and that
actually would have been the prologue to
the second infinity war which is where
this stuff actually is going to happen
because this is all why the next
infinity war is where the remaining
characters are going to go about
reversing everything that just happened
in this movie don't do that that's
that's cheating okay you cheated me out
of thirty five bucks because I had to
spend a bunch of money go to the
ArcLight with my wife to see this thing
so I could talk about it and again did I
not enjoy I enjoyed it I enjoyed it but
you can't make me feel emotionally like
there's one particular death where they
do it and they are so attempting to
strangle you as an audience member
they're still attempting to strangle
tears out of you as an audience member
in the way this character dies and
you're like but he's not dead like I
know he's not dead I know for a fact
he's not dead because there's a movie
slated on the books with this star a
year from now so he's not dead right so
you're lying to me you're trying to like
machine in in the show friends where
there's a there's a a an anniversary for
Ross and r84 for Ross and what's
Courtney Cox's character's name and it's
not Rachel it's the other one they in
any case Monica thank you with Ross and
Monica's parents and Monica is and Ross
can always make the parents cry at the
at the anniversary and Monica
desperately wants to make the parents
cry so she does a speech and the parents
aren't crying at all and she just starts
telling stories about like when the dog
died and all this sort of thing like
there is that moment in an Avengers
infinity war where one of the characters
is like basically the producers are
saying like you need to cry now if
you're not crying out is your bad person
why aren't you crime
why aren't crime it's wrong with you
aren't you and I'm not crying I know
he's not dead that's why I'm not crying
you okay so was it bad no it was
enjoyable but am I going to give them
the the credence of pretending am I
going to pretend along with them that
any of these people are really dead no
because I'm not a stupid idiot okay so
there is my infinity war summation and
and now if I if I spoil the movie for
you sorry but I gave you fair warning
you could have tuned out earlier and
then listen to it later anyway we'll be
back here tomorrow with all the rest of
the news and hopefully I will have
I will evented my spleen about Avengers
infinity bar by then I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Plummer executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018